man Kanye West everybody talking about
Kanye West yeah you keep saying things
and you think okay he can never top that
and then he comes along any top set yeah
unbelievable yeah Kanye West you
probably heard this Kanye West is under
fire for an interview with TMZ where he
describes slavery as a choice said
slavery is a choice yeah you know it's
never a good sign when the moral high
ground in a room is held by the people
of TMZ that's kind of frightening
actually cooler heads at TMZ prevailed a
group of House Republicans has nominated
president Trump for a Nobel Peace Prize
yeah as evidence they pointed out that
Trump has managed to avoid an all-out
war with North Korea and Melania
that's my Trump that's all it is I push
this forward and I look like I ate a
lemon watching Fox eating a burger
that's all I got enough to do the voice
or anything
thank you hair more bad news for Bill
Cosby yeah yeah Yale University has
taken back the honorary degree of Dave
Bill Cosby took it away yeah it's
particularly embarrassing because it was
a PhD in chemistry so how are y'all
doing everything good all right thank
you
I like that reaction that's always my
favorite
make up your minds man hey today Harry
Potter author JK Rowling apologized for
killing the character Dobby the
house-elf in book seven yeah then she
should a separate apology to people
who've just finished reading book six
number when you got to that part four
weeks you were like I didn't read those
books I watched the movies alright true
fans true fans just watched the movies
7-eleven has announced they are going to
be offering healthier options for their
customers yeah there you go that's nice
the CEO said we want our customers to
live to be as old as one of our hotdogs
so some critics some critics are now
saying that the NASS that I'm sorry some
critics are now saying that NASA will be
unable to use space X's rocket because
it's too small yeah however SpaceX
insists that's that's just the cold
weather and shouldn't
I want to apologize to everyone because
that was not worth our time and I could
have stopped that joke I could have I
could have stopped it and I didn't and
if I had to do it all over again I still
would go ahead and do that I'm being
honest with you there like a penis when
it's cold okay
you